Hanover's historic center the city wants
to make sure its visitors and tourists
don't miss a single sight or attraction
that's why they came up with this little
red line
it runs 4 kilometers through the city
guiding you to 36 of its most important
sites including plenty of examples of
Hanover's royal splendor this city was a
seat of royal power for more than 200
years home to the later Kings of Hanover
from one of Europe's oldest noble
families this was supposed to be their
new palace but the king of Hanover was
stripped of power by the Prussians in
1866 and never got to move in
instead the palace remained empty for
ten years until a university took over
the building Hanover's Opera House is
another example of royal architecture
the King wanted to locate the building
in what was then the city centre and the
architects had to fight hard to get
their project on its outskirts approved
but in the end Hannover grew and
developed around the Opera House
Hannover continued to grow in size and
splendor under Prussian rule to
from the cupola visitors have a
panoramic view of the city
right in the heart of Hanover the
man-made mush say Lake is one of
Hanover's many green oasis the city
boasts that it's Germany's greenest
the gorge garden landscape park is an
example of this visitors taking a stroll
through the Royal Gardens are
transported back to the 17th century The
Closer garden was the centerpiece of the
electus summer residence it was
envisioned and realized by Electress
Sophia of Hanover who wanted to create a
kind of outdoor ballroom the central
focus of the garden is this fountain
which shoots water 80 meters into the
sky and don't leave the Royal Gardens
without seeing the grotto designed by
Nikita sulfa
here the artist has created a magical
world made up of colorful mosaics
once controversial the Nana's sculptures
are now an integral part of the city
Hannover has been investing in public
art since the 70s
of course there's indoor art - like the
algis Kastner Museum
it houses antiquities including pieces
from ancient Egypt as well as examples
of modern design
the spinal Museum focuses on
contemporary and classic art
the world-renowned museum features up to
25 temporary exhibitions every year
Hanover blends royal splendor green
retreats and a rich cultural heritage to
make it a great place to live and visit